dispuestos a compartir las preciadas
vacunas pero la promesa de la casa
blanca de exportar 60 millones de dosis
de astrazéneca viene con un
inconveniente las inyecciones no pueden
ser enviadas al extranjero hasta que
sean autorizadas por los reguladores
estadounidenses
sólo para ser claros en este momento
tenemos cero dosis disponibles de
astrazéneca la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos tiene que pasar
por una revisión para garantizar la
seguridad
esperamos que hay aproximadamente 10
millones de dosis que podrían ser
distribuidas sólo cuando la rda de su
consentimiento lo que podría ocurrir en
las próximas semanas más de la mitad de
la población adulta de eeuu ya ha
recibido una primera inoculación
mientras que otros países como india
necesitan desesperadamente vacunas yobái
de nabucco narendra modi el lunes
prometiendo insumos médicos pero la casa
blanca no especificó si las vacunas
serían parte de esa ayuda una ayuda que
no es sólo altruista
cada variante que hemos visto surgir en
esta pandemia ha acabado en eeuu no hay
forma de aislarse así que aunque lo
hagamos por razones egoístas todos
deberíamos comprometernos a ayudar a los
países a mantener sus brotes bajo
control y prestar especial atención a
países como india que tienen una
población tan grande y tantas
infecciones que se están registrando en
este momento a diferencia de china a
rusia y la unión europea que han estado
exportando mientras inoculaban eeuu ha
sido criticado por acumular vacunas el
mes pasado prestaron dosis a méxico y
canadá y ahora esta nueva promesa
constituye un cambio significativo en
las primeras incursiones de washington
en la diplomacia de las vacunas